qu'est-ce que ce sera un
art de patchouli supplémentaire qui est un plafond si vous le regardez
tous les soirs, cela semblerait si effrayant quand
vous y arriverez, vous savez comment quand vous rencontrez
quelqu'un et qu'il est déjà la
personne qu'il est censé être c'était Adam
moi  pas tellement
Adams ici les enfants faites attention là-bas
ici ça devient assez sauvage c'est Symphony
J'ai ce Julian Tomas dans toute ma
vie Je ne peux pas me cacher dans cette salle de répétition
pour toujours il est trop tard
tu vois n'est-ce pas incroyable comme la vie est une
chose et puis en un instant ça devient
autre chose comme whoa suis-je en train de mourir
voici le bébé secret si tu vis si
tu meurs c'est à toi de dire quelque chose
c'est réveiller une orpheline hein
si elle se réveille qu'est-ce que je suis censé faire
parfois  tu fais des choix dans la vie et
parfois les choix te font te sentir
mieux frappe ça tu vois tu es maintenant est
le même toi dont j'étais amoureux
hier tu as toujours une famille à côté
de moi la vie est ce gros gros
gâchis puant gigantesque c'est la beauté de celui-ci  -
Je suis encore là  et je suis fou amoureux
de toi euh s'il te plait reste
toi